okay so it's time to get started
so I'm Tomas westrom and I'm going to
introduce this year's laureate Ron
Tyrone so this this year's prize is
about the behavior of powerful firms and
how they should best be regulated
economists tend to think of competition
as a good way to provide high quality at
a low price for the consumer but there
are markets where for various reason
competition doesn't work that well and
there are even markets called natural
monopolies where it may be difficult to
have any real competition at all that
those may be markets for example where
some dominant firm is controlling some
resource such as a railroad company
controlling or owning the railroad
tracks and it may be difficult to
duplicate those tracks so it may be very
quite wasteful to build multiple
parallel tracks for railroads so the
question is then what is the best public
policy towards those kinds of dominant
firms so this year's laureate is is
awarded this prize for for his analysis
of market power and regulation jean
tirole was born in 1953 he got his PhD
from the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology and he is now the he's now
located in he's not
back to France so he's now the
scientific director at the Institute
economy industrial at Toulouse School of
Economics and I am not going to say much
about his scientific research which in
any in any case it's impossible to
summarize in in even in him even in a
book much less in a few few words he has
worked on the fear of industrial
organization and has his very well-known
in among graduate students in economics
for his wonderful textbooks although you
are obviously not awarded this prize for
a book is still a very wonderful
contribution and he has a number of
papers with jean-jacques Lafont and in
particular many of the papers on I think
almost all of the papers regulation of
natural monopolies were with Professor
Lafond so I've listed a few more a few
more notable articles by professor to
role but I would actually like to invite
him now to come up on stage and talk
about his own work so if professor troll
could
well Thank You Thomas Falls was vacant
words it's a lecture of a unlike any
lecture I've ever given
it's filled with emotions with
intellectual in depth eNOS and who is
very fond memories so it's it's really
amazing experience in us
economists have long extolled the
virtues of markets and federal
competition protects consumers from
political whims and force his producers
to deliver products and services at cost
alas competition is really perfect
markets fail and market power of the
firm's ability to raise price above cost
or to offer low quality must be kept in
check initial organization studies
exercise and control of market power to
this purpose it builds models that
capture the essence of the situation the
predictions of the model can then be
tested econometric ly and possibly in
the lab in the end the reasonableness of
and robustness to modeling assumptions
and the quality of one vehicle fit
determine how confident we are in making
recommendations to policy makers for
interventions and to companies for the
design of their business model in this
organization as a long tradition first
theoretical with the work of French
engineer economist August econo and Jill
Dupree then policy oriented with
enactment of the Sherman Act in 1890 and
subsequent legislation legislation then
descriptive with the studies of the
Albert school structure conduct
performance
conforting and refining the antitrust
drive and finally skeptical with a
chicago school the chicago school
correctly pointed out that there was no
underlying theoretical doctrine and it
went on to cast doubt on the whole
edifice
it however didn't develop an alternative
antitrust doctrine perhaps because it
was broadly suspicious of regulation by
the late seventies and early eighties
the antitrust and regulation doctrine
was in shambles and not to be rebuilt
the modern intellectual corpus at an
emerge at them has been very much a
collective effort involving not only me
but also my closest collaborators on the
topic and very unfairly to the others
drew foodon Berg Eric Maskin jaw Chuck
lafoon to whose memory this lecture is
dedicated Patrick crash or shall Hoshi
paul-jules Cohen Josh Lerner and the
many many scholars whose own work
discussion with me and comments on my
articles and books have deeply
influenced my thinking by being on those
of spotlight today owes more to their
contribution than to my own talent but I
claim credit fiving been in the right
places at the right time and in having
learned from fabulous colleagues and
students in the area for which the prize
was awarded many other fields as well we
sometimes a bit of luck as when my MIT
fellow classmate and like me Eric mask
in advisee drew Freudenberg told me
about an interesting field I didn't even
know what in this reorganization meant
at that time an orderly pass my journals
but then I decided to sit in fascinating
lectures even by Paul Roscoe and each
man Z and I started fruitful
collaborations with drew a stroke of
good fortune indeed as a required tools
game theory and information economics
were witnessing a series of
breakthroughs on the policy front there
was widespread recognition that all
style public utility regulation led to
inflated cost and to poor customer
satisfaction so reforms were called for
to Chronicle
institutional change favor the use of
economic reasoning
where disputes were settled and
negotiation regulation design opaquely
in the minister's office transparent
processes run by independent agencies
were put in place for instant
competition authorities and regulatory
agencies sprung up in Europe which use
economic reasoning this most fortunate
conjunction of circumstances led to a
new paradigm as well as alpha sized by
the Prize Committee scientific
background report this paradigm is rich
and complex first counting the number of
firms all the market shares provides
only a very rough indication of whether
the market is competitive second is
industries of their specificities
competition in information technologies
payment cards innovation or segments is
different economies accordingly have
advocated a case by case or rule of
Reason approach to antitrust away from
rigid per se rules which mechanically
either allow or prohibit certain
behaviors the economies message however
comes with a social responsibility first
economies must offer rigorous analysis
of our markets work taking into account
the specificities of particular
industries what regulators do and do not
know this latter point for new calls for
information light policies that is
policies that do not require information
that is unlikely to be held by
regulators second economists must
participate in the policy debate the
financial crisis whose main ingredients
could be found in academic journals
before the crisis is a case in point but
of course here the responsibility goes
both ways policymakers and the media
must also be willing to listen to
economists regulators affect industries
in multiple ways
sector sector all regulators in telecoms
electricity railroads or postal services
regulate incumbent operators rate of
return and monitor the conditions under
which they give access to the
bottlenecks or to the bottlenecks that
they control antitrust authorities allow
or invalidate horizontal as well as
vertical mergers and agreements and
decide whether certain behaviors and
contractual covenants constitute an
abuse of dominant position patent and
trademark offices and courts grant
apalled a recharger patent determine its
scope its breadth whether the grantee
can seek injunctions and so forth
ultimately these various forms of
regulation have in common that
regulators face a trade-off between
lowering the price for the users thereby
ensuring a wider diffusion and granting
a fair rate of return to the firm
consider for example the foreclosure
doctrine it's the modern form an
upstream firm you as a unique access to
an essential facility infrastructure or
bottleneck input some inputs that cannot
be reproduced at a low cost a railroad
tracks and stations network a power
transmission grid a key patent the issue
is whether the upstream firm should give
an equal access to all downstream
suppliers alternative train operators
power producers technology implementers
which I call d1 dkd and in the figure
search for access allows downstream
firms to compete for the end-users on a
level
the downstream competition enabled by
fair access dissipates a profit that can
be extracted from end users you'll get
lower prices and so because the upstream
profit is capped by this downstream
profit fair access Giada's is the
ability of the upstream firm to profit
from the essential facility in practice
therefore the upstream firm often favors
is dancing is the on stream subsidiary
which I call d1 the figure in a myriad
of ways for example by refusing to deal
with rivals or grants and license by
charging prohibitive access prices or by
making its technology incompatible with
that of the rivals if not vertically
integrated it meant a sweet deal with
the downstream firm to the same effect
in short the upstream firm uses
exclusivity to restore its market power
for example a biotech Technology biotech
company with a patent on a new drug will
grant exclusive right for the Product
Approval production market marketing
stages to a single pharmaceutical firm
either in US for example Sanofi for
genzyme or external so whether the
antitrust Authority tolerate such as
crucial behavior or not the factor
regulates a rate of return on the
upstream infrastructure the essential
facility now the question is should the
authority clamp down on searches
crucially behavior the common sense
answer to this question in G's on that
to the following question does the
bottleneck result from an investment and
innovation o else does it resolve from
political connections wrong market
design or sheer luck simply is there an
investment worth of a reward or not for
instance the beneficiary of a highway
Harbor Airport concession deserves its
money people
if the monopoly position was acquired
through a competitive world is an option
but it was a quiet free-of-charge also
biased auction design an inventor should
be allowed to exploit the innovation
himself or grant an exclusive license if
the innovation is major but not if the
innovation lacks novelty or is obvious
but nonetheless is protected by
intellectual property law utility
unreasonable profit investment but not
benefit from lucky cost and demand
conditions the same reasoning underlies
much of antitrust doctrine which
following Schumpeter
doesn't condone the existence of
monopoly power but France upon the
further acquisition of mock market
powers through merger or the use of
positive dominant position regulators
face a double asymmetry of information
called adverse selection and more as are
respectively first regulators have
superior knowledge I'm sorry regulated
firms have superior knowledge about the
environment their technology the cause
of their inputs the demand for their
products and services second they take
actions that affect cost and demand
human resource management strategic
source of plan capacity R&D and brand
image quality control risk management
and so forth and surprisingly
authorities that neglect the Scimitar of
information fail to deliver effective
cost efficient regulation there are two
broad principles here the first is
obvious authorities should attempt at
reducing the asymmetry of information by
collecting data of course by
benchmarking the firm the firm's
performance to that of similar firms
operating in different markets and
finally by auctioning off the monopoly
rights because in an auction
firms reveal information about industry
cost when competing with each other
Sudan principle is that one size doesn't
fit all once you let the rigid firm make
use of its information but before we get
to this imagine that you're in charge of
dealing with a contractor two familiar
contracts will probably come to your
mind you can offer to fully reimburse a
contractor's cost plus some set payment
over this cost such a contract is called
a cost blast or rate of return
regulation or you can fix the total
payment and tell the firm that this
payment will cover its return as well as
its cost whatever the latter turns out
to be such a contract is called a fixed
price or price cap contract the two
contracts differ in the strength of the
incentives of the incentives which are
provided to the contractor the cost
price contract shelter the firm's from
situations in its cost performance it's
a completely insured the fixed price
contract by contrast makes a firm fully
accountable for its cost performance so
the fixed price contract obviously lease
its most more cost reducing effort from
the firm it however has a drawback of
leaving substantial profit to the firm
in lucky circumstances in which cost
turn out to be particularly low or
demand I independently of any effort
made by the firm returning to the one
size doesn't fit all ID one can show
that the regulated firms should be
controlled confronted with a menu of
options to oversimplify this menu might
take the form of a choice between a
fixed price and a cost per contract then
the firm's self selects an efficient
firm will opt for the fixed
contract because it want to be made
accountable for its cost in those that
its cost will be low while an
inefficient firm will offer the
protection of cos plus of reimburse cost
powerful incentives have been key to
remedy the dismal cost performance of
traditional regulation however theory
and practice offer some caveats first
making the firm accountable for its
cross performance also provides a firm
with an incentive to skim quality so
powerful incentive must go together with
a more thorough monitoring of quality
second the observation that powerful
incentive generate both a high effort
and I profit or rant implies that
regulators cannot have their cake and
eat it too while the regulator's under
the pressure of public opinion may be
tempted to take back this rant those
profit exposed such positive policy
reversal destroys in firms incentives to
reduce cost wider knowledge of this
principle would have prevented some
wishful thinking when powerful
incentives were introduced
thus powerful incentive require
commitment this commitment in terms
requires an independent regulatory
agency protect it from the pressure of
public opinion third the policy
possibility of iran's increases benefit
for the firm of capturing its regulator
so if you cannot guarantee the
regulator's independence from the
industry don't go for high powered
incentives the essence of regulation is
often to ensure that undeserved market
power doesn't translate into a high of
all prices traditionally so regulators
have gone way beyond this price level
regression
they have also mingle with a ratio of
prices
that is with a price structure there too
they face is substantial information on
the gap more further need for
intervention is much less obvious and in
the case of the price level what it is
clear that the monopoly has incentive to
charge higher prices very i price is it
is a priori less clear that it is biased
in his choice of letting blob rather
than Hana bear the brunt of market power
in 1956
Marcel water building on earlier work by
Frank Ramsey sure that regulated firms
should exhibit a price structure similar
to ordinary unregulated once the price P
I in segment I should be low if the
segment is cheap to serve so the cost CI
is low because of serving this segment
is law and demand it is high that is if
a price increase implies a substantial
reduction in demand thus regulated firms
should be from spices should be
disoriented they are very similar to but
overall lower than the price of an
unregulated monopoly the CETA in this
formula is less than one so you reduce a
prices without completely changing the
price structure yet regulators used to
form to foster agreed to set they
economically very inefficient why
structures this price tinkering away
from rancid water principles was
motivated by the correct premise that
regulators do not process the
information but cause and demand to
fine-tune prices in a business oriented
fashion this reasoning however ignores
the possibility of making use of the
centralized information a global price
cap regression in which a firm must only
comply with some cap on its weighted
average price
not only create powerful incentives for
the firm by making it accountable for
its cost but also lets affirmed free to
choose its price structure in a business
oriented fashion a special case of this
idea arises when one of the products
supplied by the monopoly is an
intermediate input that is a provision
of access for rivals to an essential
facility so we come back to the
foreclosure doctrine by imposing access
prices at marginal cost assuming they
can measure it regulators de facto bias
a price structure and focus markups
entirely on those segments as final
segments for which the essential
facility order faces no competition this
is bound to be very inefficient
reportedly interesting price choice of
price structure arises in so-called
two-sided markets two-sided platforms
bring together multiple user communities
that want to interact with each other
gamers and game developers for video
games users of operating system and apps
developers for operating systems
eyeballs and advertisers for search and
media platforms card holders and
Merchants for payment card transactions
the challenge for those two-sided
platforms is to find a viable business
model that gets both sides on board
regardless of their market power whether
whether they are Google or free
newspaper like Metro they choose to
allocate a lower burden to the site said
are in this formula whose presents
benefit most user on the other side in
this equation vga represents how much a
site j user values an extra user on side
i this willingness to pay for an
interaction with an extra user
I can be recouped by the platform
through a price increase on side J so if
you bring an extra user on Saturday the
users on side J will have an increased
surplus that you can recoup so an
increase in price on on side J the
platform's reveal real opportunity cost
is there for the platform's production
costs ypres interaction which can be
zero in practice it's often zero minus
VJ platforms also like ordinary
businesses choose a lower burden for the
side which has a relatively high last
year demand it I in this formula this
formula very often results in very
skewed pricing patterns when with one
side paying nothing a free search engine
free portal free newspaper or even being
paid to enjoy the service as when you
are count older and you get frequent
flyer miles or cash back bonuses for
using your card while the other side is
a very taxed a regulator failing to
understand the nature of two-sided
markets but misleadingly complain about
predation on the right side or even
excessive pricing on the I price side
despite the fact that such pricing
structure and patterns actually practice
by even by small entering firms
regulators should refrain from
mechanically applying a standard on
stress IDs where they do not belong this
doesn't mean that regulators should turn
a blind eye when facing two-sided
markets a case in point is provided by
platforms that supply a service to their
members but are not the only route for
purchase for instance American Express
provides a card holder with a service
but also payment
thoughts like cash check other cards are
also available so those are routes for
purchase the hotel or airline flight can
be booked either through an online
booking platform like booking.com
or directly such platforms usually
charge emergency and demand the price
coherence price clearance means that the
merchant is not allowed to charge more
for transaction performs through the
platform then for transaction that
doesn't use it while price coherence
sound theoretical justifications because
it prevents surcharging all dubs by the
merchant it also comes with hazards for
a merchant fees in part pass through to
third parties namely the consumers who
do not use a platform so those consumers
who do not use the platform actually
going to pay more for that purchase
because part of the merchant fee charged
by the platform will be passed through
by the merchant to consumers this may
result in excessive merchant fees the
market failure in this instant is not a
secured pricing pattern which is very
typical of two-sided markets but the
externally on the non-contracting
parties which do not choose a platform
the analysis reveals that the merchant
fee should obey the following Jovian
principle in the case of car payments
the merchant fee should be equal to the
benefit that the merchant derives from a
card payment the consumer who decides on
the payment method whether to use a card
or use cash or checks then exerts no
externality on the merchant because the
merchant pays exactly is benefit from
card payments
this very simple Pigovian principle is
now the European Commission's doctrine
for regulating open system Visa and
MasterCard in this realm as in many
others neither less affair nor shotgun
regulatory approaches wanted only sound
economic analysis will do the rule of
Reason approach the competition policy
requires some confidence as to which of
efficiency and anti-competitive effects
dominates in this respect simple rules
greatly strengthen confidence in policy
choices consider intellectual property
for which a shortage of data can be
acute with technology is not having yet
eaten the inter ground biotech and
software technologies are often covered
by a multiplicity of patterns of varying
importance and owned by different owners
this patterns thicket is conducted on
conducive to royalty stacking or in the
jargon of economists multiple
marginalization to understand what is
stacking which was brilliantly
formalized in 1838 bogus Nakano and more
recently by Cal Shapiro it may be useful
to return to medieval or Europe whose
River transit was hampered by a
multiplicity of tolls for example there
were 64 tolls on the Rhine River in the
14th century each tour collector set its
toll to maximize revenue oblivious of
what this meant not only for the users
would pay a high price but also for the
other toll collectors who suffer from
very low traffic
Europe had to wait until the Congress of
Vienna in 1815 and subsequent
legislation to read to settle remove all
of tall stacking eye technologies are
currently witnessing an evolution
similar to river traffic in the 19th new
guidelines have been set so as to
encourage a co-marketing
of intellectual property through patent
pools patent pools organizations in
through which owners of patents get
together to come rket their patents
licenses patent pools reducible price of
licensing complimentary patents
benefiting both technology users but
also intellectual property owners Alice
button pulls and more Julie co-marketing
arrangement may allow may also allow
firms to raise price for example the
owners of to substitute patterns like
the two toll collectors in the two
branches of the river here can raise
licensing price by forming a patent pool
setting a collective toll for the
downstream F access in a figure it's
very keen to a cartel or merger to
monopoly instead of lowering the price
it's going to raise the price to the
user a flashback is used for again a
little-known fact is that prior to 1945
most major industries were run by patent
pools actually when I grew up and
studying in this organization I didn't
know the word patent pool and the reason
for that is a decision by the US Supreme
Court in 1945 the worry of about
catalyzation led through joint marketing
led to a nostril decision of the US
Supreme Court in 1945 and the
disappearance of pools until the recent
revival of in
tres but kulit competition authorities
just ban bad price increasing pool and
allow good price decreasing pools the
unfortunately do not process a relevant
information there is often no longer
story of licensing and a pattern of
substitue bility of complementarity
changes with the uses that are made of
the technology simple regulation however
allows such sorting first individual
licensing the ability for individual
owners to keep licensing their patent
outside the pool recreates competition
when pattern pools will otherwise have
raised price pattern pools with
individual licensing therefore
neutralized by pools way allowing good
ones to achieve the price reduction so
here you see the owners of patent one
and pattern to form a pool kkoma get
their licenses but also free to compete
with the pool because they keep
ownership of their pattern and therefore
if it's a collusive arrangement if the
patterns are rather substitute you they
can compete with a pool second and to
counter the threat of tacit collusion it
is wise to append a signal information
free requirement called unbundling under
unbundling the users can bind your
licenses from the pool not only the
bundle itself and the pool price for
multiple licenses is a sum of his
individual prices interestingly both
precepts in the euro licensing and
unbundling derive from theory have been
incorporated in the European guidelines
in 2004 and 2014 respectively
another information free presser for the
treatment of intellectual property or
rigidity originating from surgical work
is a suggestion that intellectual
property owners commit to a cap on their
licensing price before storage is
financed so we need startups because
there are networks nullities the various
actors in the industry Murs interoperate
but the issue with a start-up is that it
may create monopolies when Studdard is
designed in many cases there are
multiple routes to solving a given
technological poem each one of these
routes may be equally viable but often a
stuttered sitting body will choose only
one avenue to pursue the analogy the
public authority map enabled traffic on
the upper branch of the river by
installing a building a lock on that
branch or may be the presence of a major
city on the upper branch may have made
this branch a superior alternative so
that actually this branch which was an
equally viable route
actually is no longer a viable one once
a startup setting decision has been made
however the chosen patent becomes what's
called a studded essential patent
because the users have to use that
patent then it can ask for monopoly
price and the patent owner therefore can
ask for higher Alti even so another
patent could have offered compatible
value at the technology been designed
differently to rest range firms from
taking advantage of the four treatises
on charity of their patents and the
centrality that resulted only from being
including in stunnin started setting
bodies commonly require firms to commit
in advance to license a patent on fair
reasonable and non-discriminatory and
the problem with this approach is at
Frank
mittens are very ambiguous what is
exactly a fair and reasonable rate and
in fact large lawsuits involving the
major actors in the industry regarding
the meaning of the commitment
proliferate all over the world you will
not built a house on a piece of land
without knowing at what price you'll be
able to buy the land the same obtains
for technologies we economists have
proposed that intellectual property
owners commit to their licensing
conditions prior to the choice of
Stoddard or also stall collector should
be basically committed to maximum price
before one is chosen one branch is
chosen to install a lock so we try to
explain also why this commitment hasn't
showed up yet of a little and why the
start of setting ovulation haven't
required a commitment to licensing price
before the story is set and again we
have to think about how we should be
using regulation to do that serie of
industry organization has proved a major
tool to think about one of the major
challenges of economies it has fashion
antitrust and regulation recognizing
that antitrust industries igniting that
industries are different from each other
and so one size doesn't fit all
it has patiently built a body of
knowledge that has helped regulators to
better understand market power and the
effects of policy interventions and
firms to formulate their strategies
industry organization has gone a long
way but much work remains to be done an
especially gratifying aspect is that the
feel of Industry organization is
currently thriving with many young top
researchers producing exciting work
making this world a better world is the
economy's first mission I believe that
the entire community of industrial
organization researchers has contributed
substantially to this mission on
community humble ordered and grateful to
be awarded the 2014
Swagger's fix bank price in acrylic
science in memory of Alfred Nobel thank
you
thank you very much thank you so if you
have to step off from behind the podium
there can be a photo opportunity
thank you
you